[Music]
[Applause]
Seth Davis CBS sports college basketball
analyst he joins us every year at this
time senior writer for the athletic good
to see you again Seth give me the result
last night that surprised you the most
well uh good morning to you
um I can't say I was surprised by any of
them to be honest uh
um I did go 4-0 in my picks last night
for the Athletics so I should just
disappear right now
um if that will never happen again you
know Florida Atlantic I'm a big believer
Dan that winning is a habit and they've
now won 34 games to three losses and
people I I would hope that we've come
far enough to understand that it's not
because they're in a bad League
Conference USA is actually not a bad
league as mid major leagues go it's
about as good as there is
um and they dominated uh all season long
um you know as a story Kansas state is
hard to beat they only had two players
coming back
um from a a program that had a job
opening for a reason
um and Jerome Tang came in and brought
in a whole bunch of new guys they were
picked to finish last in the Big 12 at
the start of the season for a good
reason and
um they have been great all year it's
not like oh my God they got hot laid and
are on this amazing tournament run they
have been good all season long
um and you saw last night you know the
power of having the two best players in
a game now of course game went to
overtime they could have easily lost
obviously but
um it's it's been an amazing story for
them so
um and then you know Yukon to me I think
Uconn and Alabama have been the best two
teams in the tournament and after last
night I would probably put Yukon one
Alabama too let's see how the tide looks
tonight so
um yeah it's just a great great night of
basketball in the crazy shot by Julian
Strother of Gonzaga to end the Knight
um really really unfortunate for UCLA
after the amazing season they've had for
them to be down two starters at this
point in the season they were they were
gassed the hallway the fact that they
took Gonzaga to the edge like that is is
an incredible tribute to Mick and those
kids so it's been a fun tournament it's
almost like we we've redefined what a
Cinderella is
now I I talked to you know Princeton's
head coach and he said we're embracing
Cinderella where Florida Atlantic is not
they they're like no we're we belong
here Kansas State as a three seed has a
Cinderella feel to them which is pretty
amazing I don't know if any of these
other schools would be defined as
Cinderellas in previous years and maybe
not now
yeah I don't think so I mean I would
agree with you I mean you know we could
talk about San Diego State you know
being a Mountain West School I mean
there are five seeds so if that's we're
you know we're kind of scraping the
bottom of the barrel for Cinderella
there you know I mean I've I've said
many times Dan San Diego State is is the
best
um mid-major program in the country
outside of Gonzaga they are really
really good every year and let's not
forget in 2020 when the tournament
canceled they were headed for a one or a
two season so um they've been good now
for many many years being able to
replenish their roster you know going
back to the Kawhi Leonard teams of Steve
Fisher
um transferring that from Steve Fisher
to to Brian Dutcher and and and
continuing that success that doesn't
that doesn't usually happen if you're in
the sweet 16 I mean I understand
Princeton is a 15th seed and we call
them a Cinderella but I mean if you if
if you didn't know anything about the
teams and you watched that Princeton
Missouri game you didn't know anything
about them where they're ranked where
they were seated what league they were
in you say oh yeah Princeton's a better
team I mean they just don't dominated
them physically so um yeah I think we're
long past the point of of of thinking
along those lines but it's an incredible
story you know ivy league champ is a
number 15 seed and what after you did to
beat Purdue as a 16 beating a one that's
going to happen again we now know it's
only a matter of time and probably not a
very long time uh before a 16 seed
reaches the sweet 16. it's it's been the
trajectory of the sport really since
I've been covering it now which I hate
to say is is uh is a good 30 years and
and and increasing fast
Seth Davis CBS sports college basketball
analyst and Senior writer for the
athletic joining us on the program it
feels like those teams those schools
that have players who stay longer than
one year
they're the most dangerous and and you
know Kentucky proved that for many many
years they would have one and done and
tons of talent and they'd go on to make
millions and millions of dollars in the
NBA but they didn't have great success
deep into the tournament
are we changing the blueprint for
success in college basketball
yeah again I think that's another thing
that's been happening I mean if you look
at 2012 the Kentucky champ that was
Anthony Davis Michael kid Gilchrist 2015
was Duke with Jalil local for tyus Jones
Justice Winslow those are all freshmen
so those were two freshman leaning teams
now they did have older players that
were there as you know their kind of
glue guys and
um and the like but but they but they
were heavily reliant on on one and done
type talents that's really been it you
know after that it's really teams like
you know Jay Wright's Villanova's teams
and the older uh you know North Carolina
team and
um you know right right on Down the Line
uh Kansas last year you got to be older
and now Dan we're at a we're in a point
where college basketball has never been
this old because of the extra coveted
year that these players are getting so
um and then their ability to transfer
without having to sit out uh has I think
helped you know sort of water find its
level where players are going going to
places where they can play and they can
be exposed and they can have the best
experience I mean people talk about the
downsides to that but I think the
upsides really outweigh the downsides of
of giving everybody the ability to to
find the place that fits them best so
um yeah I mean like the Duke Tennessee
game last week was a great example I
mean Duke just looked really young
Tennessee is older more physical
um and and that's why they're still
playing I think a lot of these teams
tonight Texas one of the oldest teams in
the country and not just being old um
Dan but having continuity from year to
year you can get old in a transfer
portal about bringing in a bunch of old
players but if you have old players who
have played together for a couple years
that's really The Sweet Spot that I
think teams are looking for Drew Timmy
has seven career tournament games with
at least 25 points so tied with Bill
Bradley and Oscar Robertson for third
most all-time Elvin Hayes and Jerry West
tied for first with eight
so he can reach that with the next game
how will college basketball remember
Drew Timmy
that's pretty good company right there
yes that's not too bad what is that I
think he's got another year of
Eligibility he does and he won't use it
I'm trying to talk him into coming back
to Common and I owe money man come on
but he's he's made pretty clear that
he's gone
um yeah I mean you know Drew's gonna be
remembered for his personality as much
as anything I mean he just plays the
game with great joy great Verve uh I'm
not a fan of dropping f-bombs on on TV
but
um that is his personality
um you know it's funny he was kissing
Julian Strother last night he's like I'm
the biggest Julian stroller fan because
if it if that shot didn't go in all we'd
be talking about right now were his two
missed free throws funny it's funny how
fate intervenes but you know he's been a
great player and he's been in a great
program like we just take this Gonzaga
thing for granted it's it's it's really
it bought I would challenge anybody to
to find me another example anywhere in
sports anywhere of of this half
happening where this little private
Jesuit school in Spokane Washington
playing in the West Coast conference is
this dominant for this long I mean we're
now going on on 20 plus years since they
made that initial run to the elite eight
with Mark Few and everybody and it's not
just Mark I mean it's a total buying of
the university the alumni base the donor
base the community
um and then people say Well they're
league and this and that and well now
you look at their record in the NCAA
tournament and there's you can count on
one hand and only need a couple of
fingers or programs that are able to
match that and then people say oh they
haven't won a a championship are you
serious like first of all they're one
possession away and they've played in
and two championship games or one
position away against North Carolina we
are talking about Gonzaga University so
for Drew Timmy and and that story for
Gonzaga and Mark Few
um to be in the elite eight is uh
fantastic I will tell you with great
confidence the road ends here uh they
match up very poorly against UConn
everybody matches up poorly against
UConn with that that two-headed monster
at Center I love Drew Timmy he's an
incredible scorer he's a pretty uh
mediocre Defender and he's going to have
he and he and the guys are going to have
their hands full with sunogo and Donovan
Klingon on uh tomorrow
your thoughts on Rick Pitino at St
John's
you know when a when a coach it used to
be to to this conversation it used to be
when a coach got a new job I would I
would sort of uh caution the fans to be
patient say because the first thing he's
going to do is look at high school
juniors so it's another year until his
his kids his first class gets on campus
then it takes a couple years to develop
and he need a couple of good classes so
we're looking at a three to five year
process now with that transfer portal
it's instantaneous it's microwave and
what I can tell St John's fans who I
know are very excited is you know Rick
pitino's 70 years old he's a young 70
and he's a 70 year old with a chip on
his shoulder and something to prove he's
been battered and beaten down and
humiliated and dragged through the mud
and it got to the point where he didn't
think he would ever have any opportunity
to coach again and he wanted it so badly
he coached in Greece for a couple years
went to Iona and so he's going into the
he's going into this with just
incredible enthusiasm and Edge and now
he can use that transfer portal if
you're a college basketball player and
you got the chance to play for Rick
Pitino at Madison Square Garden are you
kidding me so
um he's going he's going to instantly
upgrade that roster and he's going to
coach the heck out of him and the garden
is with I mean the Knicks are playing
well and St John's is going to be back I
don't know if I'm through the Looking
Glass here what's going on or if it's a
dream uh I don't want to wake up because
it's going to be exciting good to talk
to you again Seth thank you uh enjoy the
rest of the tournament love you Dan love
you too Seth Seth Davis CBS sports
college basketball analyst senior writer
for the athletic